les pays qui sanctionne en général j'ai
pas tellement pour obtenir un objectif
rationnel c'est parce qu'il faut calmer
une partie de la population
prenez les etats-unis qui sont devenus
les champions du monde
les sanctions elles peuvent évidemment
pas ce qui ce dit l'ong
ils ont voté eux mêmes des lois qui leur
donne le droit d'intervenir contre toute
entité qui utilise le dollar à un moment
donné et comme le monde entier
l'économie mondiale et le mondialisée ce
qui est pas mal financiarisé trop
dérégulé beaucoup trop de la risée c'est
trop américains etc etc
ils peuvent intervenir sur n'importe qui
sous prétexte de lutte contre le
terrorisme la corruption mais souvent en
réalité en fait en même temps pour
assurer leur intérêt est écarté des
concurrents donc aux etats unis une
machine infernale dont les etats-unis
les européens n'ont pas assez pris
conscience est d'ailleurs la commission
devrait se doter à mon avis le système
symétrique au moins pour dissuader et
pour discuter ou des sénateurs sont
actionnées par des lobbys très précieuse
états unis mettre en marche dès des
nouvelles sanctions et comme il ya
énormément de mouvement les polonais des
états unis où les soucis cela les
ukrainiens les biélorusses mme et il ya
des gars quasiment des lobbys de tous
les peuples du monde sauf les français
pour des raisons de l'individualisme et
de manque d'organisation bref il ya des
lobbys partout qu'ils sont capables de
déclencher des sanctions américaines
le résultat c'est quasiment secondaire
en fait parce qu'il s'en fiche un peu
puisqu'ils peuvent après dire voyez j'ai
montré ma ferme était extraordinaire
face à la russie face à d'autres choses
je ne dis pas que le comportement russe
ou chinois autre est exemplaire c'est
pas le sujet allez je parle de la
mécanique interne donc et sanctions
répondent assez bien alors à leur
objectif qui est d'ordre de politique
intérieure mais je trouve ça nul 1-1
s'annulent lamentable ça n'a aucun
rapport avec une politique étrangère
vrai il ya quelques cas quand même
quelques cas il faut pouvoir se servir
de sanctions à condition qu'elle soit
intelligente et ciblées pour atteindre
un objectif de politique internationale
mais c'est assez rare parce qu'en
général elles sont contournées ça
déplace les équilibres dans les rapports
de force
et malheureusement souvent ce sont les
peuples qui les subissent
[Musique]